the car under wraps here was built 116
years ago but was lightyears ahead of
its time on january thirty first porsche
chairman Wolfgang Porsche unveiled a
true automotive sensation lights at
honda says we knew headin on Porsche had
presented a loaner portion with wheel
hub motors at the world exhibition in
paris in 1900 but no one knew he'd
already created an electric carriage in
1898 electrophysiol kuchiki mata just
was diwali Ferran on Porsche created the
electric model known as the eager loner
c2 Phaeton when he was just 23 the young
automakers creation is considered
groundbreaking today the pioneering
electric car had an astonishing range of
80 kilometers and a top speed of 35
kilometers an hour a breakneck pace of
its day
disgaea Jurgen part says Ferdinand
Porsche was a genius so he's not
surprised the car showed up here getting
a buzz a world where Maurice driver says
he's always thought Ferdinand Porsche
was a genius so this just confirms it he
marvels up the engineers foresight and
thinks it's incredible of the connors a
range of 80 kilometers on a par with
today's electric cars that's it this
comedian says he knew carriages like
this existed but that they come equipped
with such a high-tech motor was news to
him alchemy noise fun fancy leather this
actor wonders if we've been duped all
these years and automakers could have
brought electric cars to market decades
ago but he thinks it's fabulous that
something like this existed way back
then Chad Alaska gave watching his full
sentence pattern on Porsche gave the key
components of his cars a code that's how
the first Porsche got its in official
name the p1 but after finding the car in
a shed in Austria Wolfgang Porsche had
to convince others of its importance
Nick's t gotten sick Amelia not everyone
in the family was thrilled in fact we
have to keep hold of it he admits some
said it's very nice but it's hardly a
modern car isaac untrue another i'ma
darkness and Metellus out to his pasand
others but in the end Wolfgang Porsche
got his way an acquired ownership of the
first vehicle his grandfather built now
it's on display for all the sea at the
Porsche Museum and stood guard Joakim
sty school says the museum is
celebrating its fifth anniversary today
and this is the best present ever it's
sensational they can unveil it to the
public here a special moment against the
Sun da moment fillings in sofla poison
to give the new fine the attention it
deserves the museum's permanent
collection has been rearranged to make
the p1 the star of the show between race
cars and vehicles people wouldn't
normally associate with Porsche the p1
points the way towards the future
mobility at the porsche museum visitors
also get to see cars that never went
into production with some you can see
why with others you think what a shame
this is one of the things that makes the
museum so successful as detail on bagga
tells us
I'm trunks love you he says at the start
they hope for 250,000 visitors a year
now they averaged four hundred thousand
which they're very happy about to draw
the crowds they change exhibits
regularly and host for special
exhibitions a year they want the museum
to be lively and always offer something
new and he says the museum has become a
top address for cultural events in
Stuttgart mrs. Paulson was interested
cut I did ask that I think about the
porsche museum is one of the most
popular museums in stuttgart and with
the arrival of the p1 and slightly to
attract even more visitors